hi I'm Eric Voss and this is a breakdown
of Game of Thrones season seven episode
six beyond the wall and I know we're all
hurting right now
and we're scared but let's just ease our
pain with a ton of interesting details
from this epic episode this episode
opens with this strange visual of the
map table and Dragonstone as the camera
glides up north to the wall so why
aren't we seeing any person in this room
right now because we're looking from the
perspective of someone as their eye line
moves up this map whose eye line is that
most likely Daenerys is this shot for
shadows the literal flight north she
will take with her dragons later this
episode and it's interesting how
throughout this season most of the shots
of this table have been aimed in the
opposite direction southward as Daenerys
attention has been focused on the war of
the south King's Landing Highgarden
Blackwater rush but now for the first
time ever in history a Targaryen and her
dragons are redirecting their focus
north beyond the wall hey that's the
episode style in this episode we'll see
how beyond the wall translates to
characters trying to look beyond the
obstacles facing them in a present to
the real enemy they'll have to face in
the future I'll come back to this but
let's move on to the north with Jon
Snow's Magnificent Seven Samurai on the
March these little character moments
between all the men as they pair off
reveal some key insights notice this
line from torment there's been too much
time with the free folk now you don't
like kneeling
nine straight it was a great mud problem
that king-beyond-the-wall never been for
me how many of his people died just fine
so for one tour men quotes the title
this episode king-beyond-the-wall but
it's interesting to hear the free folk
suggest to Jon that it may be worth
nailing to Daenerys when Jon first met
this guy in season 3 torment consider
the whole idea of kneeling to be a joke
you grace the grace now all you'd better
kneel every time I fart stand boy they
don't kneel for anyone beyond the wall
past few episodes have actually alluded
to manses refusal to kneel a few times
John then was using it as a point of
inspiration to resist kneeling for
Daenerys
but now tormund's experiences have given
him a new outlook death is a bigger
enemy than losing your pride John and
Jorah Mormont also have a moment Don
tries to return the Mormont family
Valyrian steel sword Longclaw but
Durrell refuses and John brings up the
death of jords father Giora when he was
mutiny in season 4 now it's interesting
that this memory came up right in this
moment if you remember that episode
ended with the introduction of the night
king with the closing image being the
reveal that the White Walkers are
turning human babies into more White
Walkers and that precise moment was the
first step on a long journey by the
night King that ended with this
episode's final heartbreaking image also
notice this exchange with barrack they
don't look much like him
who's that your father I suppose you
favor your mother this is yet another
reference to the fact that John isn't
Ned's son but his stark appearance does
come from somewhere from his mother's
side Lyanna stark now this episode is a
major game changer with the deaths of a
few key characters Azaria on the dragon
Benjen stark and Thoris of mere and
let's actually chat about doors for a
second this episode strips away a lot of
his mystery and reveals him as kind of
this drunk man behind the curtain he
makes peace with Gendry with a swig of
rum and then later he confesses to Jorah
that he was so trunk for his famous
charge in a Pike that he doesn't
remember it then later after thorough
skies the Hound sips is wrong and this
is actually a callback to the first
episode of the season when Thoreau's
offered the Hound some rum the calmest
nerves but a hound refused because it
was too sweet he wanted some rum
nice [ __ ] is too sweet now Sandra is
honoring throws by taking him up on that
drink now in my last breakdown I brought
up the theory that this crew of seven
men overlooking the few other
Expendables who are clearly gonna die
these guys represent these seven new
gods facing off against the old gods the
army of the dead and if you were paying
attention and these scenes are all
filled with clues that reinforces
parallel first notice this line from The
Hound about Barry
there's nothing killed six times you
don't hear him bitching about it so if
Barrack died six times it means he's now
on his seventh life clearly the number
seven is a significant number so
tormented definitely embodies the spirit
of the warrior he craves battle welcomes
good fighting spenta [ __ ] best this
guy is a soldier dreaming of his warrior
dream girl back home Brienne and making
more warriors with her I wanted to make
babies with them in common
great big Moses they conquered the world
how did a mad [ __ ] like you live this
life I'm good at kill me also I
suggested that Gendry could be embodying
the figure the maiden now based off of
what he was doing with Melisandre I
don't know if he's technically average
the rookie of this bunch like he's never
seen snow before and he's too innocent
still to get the dirty jokes made by the
Hound and torment and speaking of the
Hound I know Gendry is technically a
Smith by trade but the Hound reflects
the spirit of the Smith he's the true
labor of this episode he works so hard
to make sure the mission actually gets
accomplished notice he's the one
dragging that white captive along and
making sure it gets Vaughn's rogue on
and in the boat later actually go check
out last week's breakdown for more on
this theory about how each character
fits in these roles now before we jump
over to the other storylines this
episode there are a few other details I
want to point out notice the arrow head
shaped Mountain that the hound
recognizes from his vision in the flames
back in the first episode now in real
life this location is in Iceland
technically it's this part I'm not even
gonna try to pronounce that now some of
you've been pointing this out to us but
yeah this is the same peak that we saw
in the background of that flashback
scene which he took from the forest in
season six when they created the night
King so yeah this whole area is the
night Kings home and point of origin
they are walking right into the lion's
den then we get this battle with the
resurrected white bear and it's pretty
intense it definitely hits a couple of
these guys on a personal level
like for instance bears are the sigil of
house Mormont which makes this a
particularly
Steen struggle for joyride it would be
like his Sansa Aria had to fight a
direwolf for Daenerys at a fight a
dragon actually notice how Jorah is the
one to take down the bear in the end he
uses this dragon glass dagger but also
barrack and thoris are using their
awesome flaming swords to weaken the
bear but it still remains alive and it's
currently on fire which yeah strikes
fear into the heart of the Hound but the
most awkward thing about this is
remember torment was rumored to have
once been de tavera
I know you never [ __ ] a bat i torment
isn't saying anything but this could be
his ex but really I would say the point
of the scene is to set up the final
twist of this episode right like now we
know that the White Walkers can turn
bears therefore they can probably turn
any beast okay so this episode jumps
back and forth a lot so before we
continue on with this storyline let's
move over to Winterfell and talk about
Sansa and Arya this episode so what the
[ __ ] is with Arya like why does she care
so much about Sansa's past shaky loyalty
to the Starks when arya herself only
recently decided to give a [ __ ] about
the family well this first scene was
since in the courtyard explains the real
reason arya brings up this memory of
teaching herself to fire an arrow now
remember the very first time we saw
early in season 1 she ditched knitting
class to go show up bran with her
archery skills and now we know the back
story that led to this moment and notice
the disk that she drops on Sansa right
before telling the story you probably
don't remember you're inside knitting
all the time oof burn so far Arya her
anger at Sansa isn't about disloyalty
this is about envy she envies her sister
for in her eyes having a more
comfortable life over all these years a
life of a lady now Arya doesn't know
about Ramsay but she can't help but
compare Sansa's inside dog life to her
life is astray she was homeless in
starving and blind she was beaten and
stabbed last episode Arya taunted Sansa
for always liking nice things to make
her feel better than everyone else
now in this episode Arya reads this
entire letter that Sansa wrote making
sure to get all the way to the end to
get to this line the Lannisters are
treating me well and providing me with
every comfort ok so then at the end of
the episode Aria plays this game of
faces with Sansa now I know the literal
interpretation of the scene is that Arya
is clearly threatening her sister but
there's also a subtextual point being
made here let's actually go back and
look at that season 5 scene when Jack
and a guard put
through this lie-detector game a girl
lies to me to the many-faced God to
herself does she truly want to be no.1
yes I'm not playing this stupid game
anymore we never stop today back in that
moment Ari revealed that deep down she
didn't truly want to be no.1 a rogue
faceless man assassin in her heart of
hearts she wanted to be a stark so
that's why ultimately she doesn't kill
her sister she just scares and
intimidates her to show her that the
monster she is had to become in order to
survive the game my faces didn't turn
out so well if the last person you must
be questions aria is referring to the
last time she played this game with the
wave and yet they didn't turn out too
good for the way but again wearing
Sansa's face has a deeper meaning for
aria this is all about envy for her who
and what it would feel like to wear
those pretty dresses to be the lady of
Winterfell and now Aria is suggesting to
Sansa that these two sisters be the same
person a lady of Winterfell who is also
a ruthless killer and Arya is telling
her that by handing her the dagger so
yes arias method here is all
intimidation but she's doing it to show
her sister that this violence is a
tactic that Sansa can use so despite all
of Littlefinger's meddling here I don't
think these sisters are divided Sansa
proves that she trusts Arya by sending
her bodyguard Brienne her only real
protector here to King's Landing and
Arya proves that she trusts Sansa by
giving her the dagger again I know
there's multiple ways to read this scene
I just think these sisters are less
divided than it seems okay let's move on
and check in on Dragonstone now here
Tyrion pleads with Daenerys to consider
setting up a line of succession in his
specific proposals interesting you say
you can't have children but there are
other ways of choosing a successor the
Nights Watch has one method the Ironborn
foot all the many floors have another
what's so tyrion is suggesting that
breaking the wheel could mean abolishing
the idea of monarchy over the Seven
Kingdoms altogether and replacing it
with something like democracy or
Republic so we mentioned the Nights
Watch remember they vote to decide their
Lord Commander in season 5 Jon won his
election by one vote in the Ironborn
hold this Kingsmoot ceremony remember we
saw your on Greyjoy winning over the
Ironborn Lords over his niece Yara so
the show is bringing up this idea of a
post monarchy Westeros to compare this
moment to a specific moment in real
world's human history so let's dive deep
into the annals of history damn I keep
forgetting to change that segment title
I'm not diving into anal ok so in the
past Kings landing has been compared to
ancient Rome and in case you didn't know
this Rome actually began with the
monarchy form of government that later
gave way to the Republic that is known
for with its Senate and elected
magistrates and a representative
assembly now of course there were some
major differences between that
historical transition and the one on the
show but the ways it lines up are pretty
crazy
the final king of Rome was a guy named
Tarquinius he married into power and
then conspired to murder the king so
that he could seize the throne this
sounds a lot like Cersei remember she
married in the power and then plotted
Robert's death after that point
Tarquinius was also extremely unpopular
he refused to bury his predecessor and
he killed off all his political rivals
Cersei also ruthlessly took out all of
her rivals and if you remember she
refused to give her predecessor her son
Tommen a proper burial ceremony been him
Barry's ashes when stood now since we're
talking about history this episode
actually uses history to inspire the
events up north as well John orders
Gendry to run all the way back to the
wall to send word to Daenerys and
ginjuries solo journey on foot here
could be a reference to the Greek Battle
of Marathon now according to legend a
lone Athenian ran a distance of about 25
or 26 miles to Sparta to seek help
before the Battle of Marathon and then
he collapsed and died of exhaustion by
the way that's why today marathons last
about 26 miles except in my case I
collapse of exhaustion in the first mile
ok let's move on and talk about this
crazy moment when John killed the white
Walker and several other White's fell
apart - probably the ones of that white
Walker turn so this is a huge game
changer and it could set up some major
implications for the show so let's be
your eyes what this could mean with
theory time okay so based on Barracks
interpretation of what went down here
the white walkers seem to be organized
like some kind of insect colony to take
out the queen or in this case the king
and all the drones die off so the idea
here is that the children of the forest
only created this one white Walker the
night King and then he was the one to
create every other white Walker after
that giving all of them the power to
resurrect whites as well so basically
this created this big happy
frozen family tree with the night king
at the base and the whole thing can be
toppled just by killing him alone this
is actually a pretty common trope we saw
it in the Avengers when all the Chitauri
soldiers shut down after Tony nuked the
mothership in space also in Star Wars
The Phantom Menace when the battle
droids were disabled now I know this
seems a little easy but the part that I
really like about this theory is it
would change the final conflict of Game
of Thrones from big army vs. big army
and White Walkers versus all of humanity
instead to a one-on-one combat the
champion of the army of the Dead versus
the champion of men and that could
confirm John as azor Ahai reborn the
prince that was promised the champion of
the Lord of Light who wields a flaming
sword to vanquish the darkness and it
would also deliver on that epic
staredown between John and the night
king at the end of hardhome actually
looking back at him now it almost seems
like the night king knows that a
showdown with John is coming also let's
not forget the idea of one-on-one combat
was foreshadowed as a solution that John
finds a lot of honor in remember last
season he pitched this option to Ramsay
Bolton before the Battle of the bastards
you're right there's no need for about
thousands of men don't need to die
listen this the old way you against me
so I think John may find himself
repeating that proposal in Game of
Thrones may and things the old way okay
moving on the second half of this
episode is centered around this ice lake
battle now there's so much tension in
the sequence and I think that's because
it borrows from some of the well-known
cinematic tropes and visuals so let's
jump into these influences in a new
section we're calling under the
influence and see what I did there jug's
okay yeah this episode is definitely
under the influence of all classic
zombie survival stories at times it felt
like I was watching The Walking Dead
like any time a white got close or win a
captive dip the hounds hand I kept
thinking oh no god you're gonna turn now
oh wait no I'm an idiot
but there are some specific moments that
borrow elements from the Walking Dead
for example the team being surrounded by
this undead horde circling up and
fighting them on all sides this is
exactly what Rick and his people do in
Alexandria in season 6 of The Walking
Dead later in the episode there's a shot
of Daenerys standing up on the wall
looking out hoping John Moore
turn on season six of The Walking Dead
when Glen disappears Maggie does that
for her long-lost lover and then there's
this quick shot of the Hound impaling
the white on one of drogon spikes to
anchor him in place we actually see this
move a lot on The Walking Dead the
Savior's actually impaled walkers on
poles outside their compound and yeah
throughout the walking that they often
capture and Corral walkers for various
reasons like to set traps or to
camouflage themselves actually this
mission also reminds me of the movie I
am Legend which isn't about zombies
they're vampires technically but the
movie made them look and act a lot more
like zombies whatever the point is these
former human monsters are revealed to be
surprisingly intelligent to have their
own culture and society just like white
walkers are and like John the main
character of I am Legend actually
kidnaps one of them so he can study it
and then eventually rid the world of
these pale threats and that really
pisses off a leader then there's another
influence I noticed check out how John's
world goes silent as he looks around at
this hopeless situation this specific
sound design is a reference to the
moments in Saving Private Ryan remember
Tom Hanks's character witnesses a
hopeless battle with the sounds of war
fading away similarly to how they do in
Game of Thrones
I know but if you think about it these
missions are pretty parallel Saving
Private Ryan is about a small band of
brave soldiers marching out into a war
zone to find one [ __ ] and bring him
home and in the end both groups are
saved by miracles from above forget
beyond the wall they should have titled
this episode Saving Private iced zombie
jugs also I got to point out how the
sword work of this battle is awesome
notice specifically the move that John
uses on this one white on the rock might
remember this is the same move that
Darth Maul used to kill qui-gon jinn in
the Phantom Menace and finally there are
definitely some influences from the Lord
of the Rings in the sequence Daenerys is
a rival with the three dragons
definitely feels like the great Eagle
saving Frodo and Sam in Return of the
King also when the Hound uses ginjuries
Warhammer to smash and collapse the
ground under the whyte that is a nod to
howl Gandalf took down the Balrog in the
mines of Moria I really wanted man to
say you shall not pass but really the
Gandalf of this battle was Danny the
grey ears we got to talk about this new
look yeah that's right
moving on from under the influence to
Game of Thrones fashion roundup so yeah
we've been talking a lot about Danny's
costume this season but one thing we
haven't mentioned is how her clothes
have been changing color and how that
reflects her transition from Targaryen
dragon Queen to Stark allied now when
she first arrived at Dragonstone her
cape was crimson red the color of House
Targaryen it's actually the same color
Cape worn by her brother and like
Viserys she arrived at this new
continent trying to put on a show
showing off the Targaryen fire and blood
shifting from the tans and blues of the
rulers of Essos to the black color
palette of the rulers of Westeros but
then halfway through the season in
episode 4 she connected with John in the
cave and he told her all about how the
children of the forest made this
alliance with the first men and during
all this her cape had changed to the
colour of gray which reflected her
shifting support to John and now of
course she's dressed in all gray
symbolizing her full support of John's
goals and in order to do that she hasn't
just had to shed her connection to
Viserys in the form of that crimson cape
she now has to sever her last remaining
connection with Viserys her dragon
vaziri on
now the death of Azarian is one of the
hardest things I've ever had to watch on
this show but there are some interesting
things going on with the visuals here if
you don't want to relive this moments
get through this time okay so yes
bazarian
does burst into flames the moment the
spear hits him it could be a nod to the
description dragons from the books as
fire made flesh but it also makes me
think about the anatomy of the Dragons
like where exactly does this fire come
from inside them now it's possible that
their whole ability to breathe fire
could be based on the real-life
bombardier beetle that insects spits
boiling chemicals out of an orifice
so maybe dragons have a similar defense
mechanism but in their case they're able
to spark and ignite that chemical and
breathe its fire so assuming that
there's some kind of gland or organ
inside of the Dragons that can do this
it looks like the night Kings spear
punctured it causing the dragon to
explode into flames kind of like the way
a fuel tank would inside of a plane now
Daenerys Lucy and Viserion must be
especially heartbreaking for her you
know what I think we deserve to honour
vissarion's memory Kazarian we hardly
knew ye seriously the show did not focus
enough on your relationship with Danny
but the books do go into more detail in
your relationships so let's dive deep
into an especially heartfelt well in the
books well in the books as Ariane is
described as the sweetest of the three
dragons actually at one point he refuses
to leave Daenerys his shoulder like a
child clinging to his mother's leg
there's another moment where Daenerys
shows misery on some extra physical
affection and then even after Viserion
has grown larger in a dance with dragons
he stays behind with Daenerys while his
brothers go out hunting and she jokes
with him that he's lazy and scratches
his jaw lovingly so yeah for Daenerys
losing bazarian is like losing the
youngest of your children now moving on
notice this shot of Jon and really
looking at the night king up on the hill
he might have recognized his shot from
the season 7 trailer a few months ago
but that version of the shot digitally
removed the night King and I love this
angle of John with drogon roaring
mournfully in the background it's like
they're framing these two dragon blooded
warriors together in anger for the
dragon the night King has taken from him
and looking closely at the night King in
his white Walker Posse notice how they
have three iced beers the same number of
dragons the same they seem awfully
prepared for Daenerys to be there and
this does add to the theory that this
was
all an elaborate trap set by the night
King Philip Amnon actually go more into
that theory in westeros weekly okay next
after Daenerys and the rest escape and
John emerges on the icy water we get
this interesting shot of John's sword
Longclaw The Wolf pommel is facing up so
clearly some creative thought went into
this shot and then something interesting
happens with his eye what the hell okay
this is spooky you know what we need a
little segment we like to call two
minutes okay zoomed in enhanced for a
second it definitely appears like that
bull's eye suddenly opens almost as if
this Wolf's head is coming to life the
moment John comes back to life now of
course if you watch this shot over and
over and over again a few times you'll
notice that unfortunately the pommel
doesn't come back to life and that eye
hole isn't turning into a pupil it's
just the darkness of John's glove
hitting the ice still I think this is a
very cool effect also the director of
this episode did claim that this wasn't
intentional but despite all that I gotta
say this shot is totally an awesome
callback to the last time John was dead
and suddenly came back to life remember
at Castle black John's corpse was laying
on the table the world went silent we
got this clear shot of go slain on the
ground eyes closed then ghosts eyes open
which is a signal to us that John is
back just like this wolf does in this
moment anyway I hope this is intentional
because I love this connection okay so
then John's Uncle Benjen appears and
saves him and yeah it's sad that he's
dead and he didn't really get a huge
moment but this does prove that his
purpose has been fulfilled his destiny
was to save two of his nephews north of
the wall also this might remind you of
that quote from Ben John's brother Ned
Stark
that Sansa said in the trailer which I
think we'll hear next episode
the lone wolf dies
but the backsides in this case this
final lone wolf
Benjen Stark has died but his death has
allowed the pack to survive okay moving
on to this steamy romance between our
favorites and nephew sweethearts okay so
this scene is loaded with sexual tension
and it's not just because John is all
shirtless and scary and he holds the
nurses hand with one hand it looks like
he's doing something else with the other
sorry I made a gross really if you look
back on this episode both of these
characters were pressured at key moments
to think about starting the family
remember earlier Jorah told John to keep
Longclaw and he said this it should be
well your children off to you then a
little later
Tyrion Joker's Daenerys that she might
be interested in John and shortly after
this he brings up the idea of her
descendants you say you can't have
children but there are other ways of
choosing successor so now on some level
their biological urges are now kicking
in also yeah this is a big moment
because Daenerys has officially seen
John's fatal scars so last breakdown I
talked about how Daenerys would be
interested in John's possible
resurrection because that's something
she tried to do to bring back Khal Drogo
so now John takes the form of the
resurrected Khal Drogo that every world
dreams of now a question why does John
finally kneel to Daenerys here so
remember earlier tormund freed John from
that archaic principle of never kneeling
just like by the way another wildling
who was kissed by fire once freed him
from his archaic vow to the Nights Watch
John of course did a different kind of
nailing then you know nothing Jon Snow
I know I keep making it gross I'm sorry
but also Daenerys finally gave John what
he had been asking for back in episode
three turning her attention northward in
fighting the real enemy and she paid a
heavy price for it so John returns the
favor and gets Daenerys which she wants
loyalty and that brings us to our
closing images the night king dredging
the corpse of Azarian and resurrecting
it with this close-up of its eye turning
this terrifying shade of blue boobalay
so not only has his image been something
that has haunted our fantasies on Game
of Thrones since the first season as yet
another physical form of the Song of Ice
and Fire the entire season has been
building up to this specific image
remember there was the opening image of
episode one that showed us another
close-up of a blue eye this time of a
resurrected giant episode 4 showed us
just how deadly dragons are against an
army of men then there was the
resurrected white bear this episode that
reminded us that giant fierce beasts
could be weaponized and then of course
last episode we got that clear close-up
of the other dragon's eye basically what
a dragon's eye looks like when it's
normal and healthy all to set up this
before and after effect hey dragons this
is your eyes this is your eye and this
is dry on the night Kings mind control
any questions so just like John's
discovery that they might only have to
kill the night king this is obviously a
huge game changer in the other direction
both sides of this war are now extremely
vulnerable and I don't imagine the night
king will exercise Daenerys is restraint
when it comes to torching the cities of
Westeros so yeah the night king has a
nuke now hold on to your butts
but let's revisit the title and the
theme of this episode beyond the wall
looking beyond your present obstacles to
your future real enemies this concept
was actually best explained by beric
Dondarrion earlier this episode when Jon
Ponder's what they're really fighting
for beric responds with this hot take
death is the enemy the first enemy and
the last but we all die the enemy always
wins and we still need to fight him you
and I won't find much joy while we're
here but we can keep others alive we
could defend those who can't defend
themselves the shield that guards the
rooms of
you may remember that last line from
John is a quote from his oath as a
brother of the Nights Watch I am the
shield that God's realm of men it refers
to the protection that the wall provides
the Seven Kingdoms
that's why later when Daenerys arrives
John refuses her hand and continues
fighting he's thinking beyond his
present obstacle to the bigger picture
the real enemy
the idea of beyond the wall also applies
to Sansa and Arya this episode their
present conflict is a resentment between
sisters the envy and distrust they feel
towards each other for the very
different choices they made since their
separation but their real enemy lies
beyond this wall Petyr Baelish as he
pulls the strings to turn these two
sisters against each other hopefully the
two will overcome this obstacle and face
the larger threat together and that
brings us to Danny
Tyrion struggled to get her to look
beyond the wall of her current battles
to the real threat of having no legacy
to leave behind but her budding romance
with John her nephew seems like it could
be her answered vet but let's remember
this decision cost Daenerys a dragon the
closing image shows us the eye of that
sacrificial lamb eater the same eye that
we were looking from the perspective of
back in the opening images soaring north
of the continent of Westeros toward a
fiery doom foreshadowed by the flames in
the background now this episode leaves
us with the eye of the real enemy more
powerful than ever before ready to make
its next move from beyond the wall do
you think Arya is right to be angry with
Sansa should just get over it I'm
curious what is your interpretation of
that scene and more importantly who do
you want to see make babies more John
and Daenerys or torment and Brienne the
answer is neither stop wanting everyone
to bang it's always weird on this show
weigh in in the comments below and tweet
your thoughts to me a da boss or to our
channel at new rockstars and if you
tweet us any questions make sure to use
the hashtag Westeros weekly so that
we'll see it and maybe talk about in our
videos and if you really like us hey why
not help us make more videos by
contributing to us on patreon big thanks
to all of our current donors especially
Wilhelmina everson thank you for
watching and see you next week for the
season finale guys it's common bye